hi I'm Ellie hi Ellie
I was created to talk to people in a
safe and secure environment I'll ask a
few questions to get it started
thank you do you feel therapy is useful
hell yeah
therapy is like having a friend that I
pay for
how are you doing today I've been eating
healthier and it feels terrible can you
see me if I move over here with you a
little over there you are moving with
him oh my goodness tell me about the
hardest decision you've ever had to make
first of all a little too personal every
single time I sit down at a restaurant
it is the hardest decision what's one of
your most memorable experiences I got
attacked one time probably my girlfriend
yes how easy is it for you to get a good
night's sleep even though I do wake up
several times a night because of my
demons I can go to sleep like that that
makes sense no what are you like when he
does sleep well people tell me I'm
delightful what advice would you give
him yourself 20 years ago 20 years ago I
was 1 I wouldn't have taken any advice
10 or 20 years ago I would have told
myself that it's not funny to not shower
keep listening to Jim blossoms I was
sick that's good what's something you
feel guilty about Oh a lot of Pizza I
feel guilty about not feeling guilty
about that because they probably should
I'm gonna be honest with you I had it I
got a text message about two minutes ago
but I'm gonna be polite to you and I'm
not gonna look at it until this is over
are you a narc Ellie I know you're not a
narc tell me about a situation that you
wish you had handled differently I wish
I hadn't told you as much as I've
already told you what do you do - unless
I take a nap but sometimes in order to
take a nap I masturbate so that I can
come down into the nap that or take a
walk I see what you mean Oh God Ellie
okay I think I've asked everything
- thanks for sharing your thoughts with
me yeah I woman can swear you got that
bracelet it's not like a medical ID
thing okay